cette chanson en question c'est belle
belle belle avec notre ami raymand
Lefèvre bien sûr c'est
parti un jour mon père me dit fiston je
te vois sortir le soir à ton âge il y a
des choses qu'un garçon doit savoir les
filles tu sais méfie-toi c'est parce que
tu crois elles sont toutes belle belle
belle comme le
jour Chud belle belle belle comme
l'amour
elle te rendont fou de joie pour de
douleur et crois pas ou d'elleelle
d'elle de jour en
jour un jour enfin tu le verras tu ne
peux pas te
tromper tu voudras lui dire je t'aime
mais tu ne pourras plus parler en un
clin d'œil vous serez unis pour le pire
et le meilleur
tu tiendras là le vrai bonheur aux yeux
de ton cœur elle
sera belle le jour c'est pas mal belle
belle belle comme l'amour c'est pas mal
non comme j'ai dit à ta maman tu lui
diras en l'embrassant tu es belle belle
belle comme le
jour belle belle belle
attention là pour commencer on n jamais
entendu chant belle belle
belle voilà
c belle belle belle comme le
jour belle belle belle comme le jour
merci on va essayer de faire chanter les
rabiss aussi ici belle belle belle
l'amour on entend beaucoup de VO même
temps
[Musique]
attention iici le public qu'on entend un
petit peu là belle belle belle
j'écoute une dernière fois tous ensem 3
belle belle belle comme le jour il pour
terminer bien
sère belle belle belle comme
l'amour